holy Usopp what a perfectly juicy
chapter to leave us with for the
upcoming four week hunger stream Buddha
Sensei really gave us a ton of meat to
chew on while we wait for the story to
continue and thank God we didn't
actually end up rushing out of one
within two chapters but we will get some
more time to wrap things up properly
let's begin right away with the new
bounties we've got Luffy law and kids
all have received an absolutely
ridiculous Bounty of 3 billion berries
making all three of them more wanted
than blackbeards I think at this Mount
Your reveal is a big surprise in a
number of ways I'm sure there are many
people who expected it to be a lot
higher than this including me honestly
but really I love three billion for a
number of reasons when you really think
about it it makes a ton of sense really
putting Luffy above Blackbeard's
underlines really nicely how impactful
his Victor over kaido really was yes
Blackbeard killing of Whitebeard and
taking his devil fruit shook the world
no pun intended actually but wipe it was
sick old and had already been fighting
against the strongest fighters in the
Marines Luffy meanwhile was facing off
against a significantly younger kaido
still in his prime and known as the most
powerful creature in the entire world
and yes I know kaido was also fighting
against the scabbards Yamato and fight
of the Supernova at once but in the end
if we're really being honest Luffy was
really the one who did over 90 of the
damage it took to really take him down
so in other words a bouncy higher than
teach makes sense now you could argue
that Luffy deserves a bouncy higher than
kaido for taking him down for example
instead of kaido's 4 billion the much
quoted 5.6 billion gomu in line with
Luffy's
we now know that there actually is no
gomukomonomi at all so I think that this
particular wordplay might well be of the
table for now the fact that taking down
both kaido and big mom did take a major
team effort in the end in my opinion
justifies a lower Bounty than them again
just because teach took out Whitebeard
didn't mean that he got a 6 billion very
Bounty afterwards I know that Luffy
usually got a higher bouncy than his
opponent because he took them out at
full strength protagonists like katakuri
for instance started at full health
against Luffy so raising his Bounty
higher than theirs did make sense at
least from an outside perspective I mean
Morgan and the government didn't really
know what was going on in the mirror
World After All however cp0 was
reporting every last detail about the
raid to the outside world and so as a
result the Bounty could be adapted a lot
more precisely on top of that putting
Luffy above kaido's level would also
have put him above Banks who has been a
yonko for much much longer than Luffy
who just turned a yonko today and so I
would assume that you would have to
repeatedly do crazy stuff like this to
actually raise your Bounty even higher
even as a yonko who knows maybe Luffy
will overtake Shanks after they have
actually met in the story which would
make a lot more sense narratively as
well I think then of course the 3
billion Barry bouncy fits in incredibly
nicely with Luffy's path so far he went
from 30 million kind of rookie bounty to
a 300 million warlord level bouncy to
1.5 billion after defeating karakuri in
other words half a yonko bounty and now
has officially entered the yonko realm
completing the three series with 3
billion berries on his flaming head then
of course there's the question why both
kit and law have gotten the same Bounty
as Luffy rightfully you might say that
Luffy is the most powerful out of these
three now I was honestly pretty
surprised myself about this reveal as
well however I really like it honestly
similarly to Luffy both law and kids
deserve pretty much 90 of the credit for
taking down big mom and I think that the
world government in the end valued the
act of taking down a yonko here and not
just power scale everyone instead of
splitting Luffy's bounty and giving law
and kids 1.5 billion berries each they
were looking at the alliance of these
three pirate captains as a whole and one
to see all three of them captured for
they threat they now pose equally it
also really nicely and honestly
unexpectedly sets up law and kit as true
Rivals to Luffy for finding the one
piece now in a way it suddenly gives
them a lot more relevance for the
remaining story than I would originally
have suspected plus it gives Luffy the
chance to distinguish himself from the
two even more in the future which is a
really important Point too I think that
I'm really really excited about giving
Luffy a mid-range yonko Bounty strongly
suggests to me that we will see at least
one more Bounty poster for him at some
point in the story reaching the true
Pinnacle of the one piece world you have
to remember that Luffy defeating the
world government will mean no more
wanted posted for obvious reasons and so
I speculated before that wano might well
be the last increase we will see for all
the straw hats but no with with this
number it really looks like we'll get at
least one more maybe after elbaf or
maybe even after Luffy becomes the new
pirate king just like Roger did now in
case you're still salty about Luffy
having the same Bounty as kid-in-law I
want to remind you that the world
government is very much aware of Luffy
being the strongest out of all these
three don't forget how much they really
Fear The Return of sun god Mika and so I
think they decided to not put that into
his Bounty but instead gave Luffy one of
the new two open spots among the four
Emperors while law and kid on the other
hand don't get that title Luffy becoming
a yonko is what really distinguishes him
from the other two now and if you don't
believe me just look at kids reaction
this chapter he thinks exactly the same
way of course he's just joking I think
when he says that he now has come for
Luffy's head but he very much
understands that the government does see
Luffy above him and law so overall I do
genuinely believe that the new bounties
are pretty much perfect especially with
Luffy now being officially an emperor
and a yonko I actually really enjoyed
that we only got these three bounties
and the new Yonker revealed this chapter
don't worry we will get to Buggy but
yeah the fact that all the straw hats
have got new bounties but we will only
be getting those after the break it's
pretty dope I think because I mean that
basically guarantees that we will have a
banger chapter right away after the
break and it also gives Oda like an
extra 50 breathing time because I'm
pretty sure that 1054 will at least be
like 50 bouncy posters now sadly enough
that won't include my own wanted poster
even though my own bounty has just
recently also been raised from 95
million that would be nice 59 million to
60 million after we hit 600
000 subscribers on the channel last week
because every single subscriber equals
100 berries on top of my bouncy honestly
thank you so much for the support it
means the world especially since we have
been at war with this man here treble
who still is almost 40 million berries
ahead of us but we're coming for you
travel we'll show you who's boss in the
ends anyways what I once again found
super interesting is how big news Morgan
is once again disobeying the
government's censorship will that get me
in trouble on YouTube for saying that or
whatever while he got the official
bounties and the yonko news from the
godosei he decided to print an image of
Luffy in gear 5 on his wanted poster
basically publishing Luffy's new Godly
appearance to the entire world a photo
that's cp0 by the way managed to take
during the fight I guess in an effort to
not let cylinder guy's death not be in
vain maybe anyways understandably the
gorosei are Furious about this
the government has tried to erase the
true nature of the Nika fruit from
history for centuries and now its
awakened form will be seen in every
single corner of the entire world that
is especially concerning because there
are people out there who will know
exactly what they're looking at I'm
thinking Shanks really maybe also
Blackbeard or dragon in other words
having some of the most powerful and
dangerous people in the world find out
that Joy boy has finally returned I will
make things even more unstable for the
government than things already were
actually also found it hilarious that
apparently the CP agents were taken out
by big mom's ship in particular
hilarious because they were completely
useless and absent for the entirety of
the raid but also because it still makes
me wonder whether big mom and kaido
might not have survived falling in a
volcano somehow in the and even if they
didn't it also raises the question what
the big man Pirates will do now that
their leader has been taken out the
Beast Pirates have all pretty much been
decimated after raid especially with
greenbolt's arrival but the big mom
Pirates are basically still fully
functional in full force so will
katakuri become a new captain and how
will he react to big mom just having
been defeated will he try to avenge her
or join forces with Luffy maybe for some
reason I haven't really thought about
this before at all but I'm really super
super curious yeah and uh speaking of
greenball what the hell just happened
there it seems like king and queen tried
to fight him and cut completely
decimated because green ball or aramaki
as he's called is an absolute monster it
turns out that he doesn't just use his
plan powers for photosynthesis to
survive but instead he literally sucks
the life force out of his opponents to
heal himself this devil fruit whatever
it exactly is might be one of the if not
the most terrifying power I've honestly
seen in the entirety of the story like
just imagine what you could do with this
you could build entire cities if you
wanted to it's basically the one piece
version of hashirama if you like his
abilities are basically perfect to take
out large amounts of medium strong
opponents all at once an incredibly
precise yet wide range attack and on top
of that he also seems to be a swordsman
just like isho carrying what looks to be
a Black Blade if I'm not mistaken so
this once again makes me wonder of
course if he's not actually someone from
juano now something else that might hint
towards that is his real life
inspiration that people on the internet
were once again pretty quick to find out
as you probably know all Admirals in the
story are inspired by Japanese actors
and green bull is no exception he's the
spitting image of yoshio harada a super
famous Japanese actor who was especially
known for two types of roles Rebels and
Samurai sometimes both we can see the
rebel in him for constantly disobeying
akino's orders and the samurai once
again might hint at a connection to wano
that I do would like to see for some
reason now I originally speculated that
he might actually be a good guy who
similarly to aokiji or maybe fujitora
will actually sympathize with Luffy's
costs however after seeing just how
brutal he is and how good he finds
akino's extreme way of doing things I'm
not so sure anymore honestly he
literally says he's coming for Luffy's
hit now he might still turn out to be a
good guy or zaro's father but it doesn't
really seem like it though honestly he
can be both zaro's father and a bad guy
at the same time I guess I have a lot
more thoughts about greenball but I'll
save all of that for a whole video on
him during the Break Meanwhile we have
the major celebration going on in the
flower Capital basically seeing the
start of the big banquet we've all been
waiting for the best thing about this
really is how it shows us just how much
Luffy has grown throughout wano banned
the new world really while still being
the very same person at heart that we
first fell in love with he doesn't want
to take away from Momo's big moment and
he sees all the people of wano eating
and drinking for free as much as they
like basically a mini version of his
dream that we got just revealed a few
chapters ago a world where all his
friends can eat and drink as much as
they like I don't know about you but to
me just seems like becoming a yonko and
beating kaido has made louvi a little
bit wiser as weird as it may sound in
regards to Luffy but for some crazy
reason there is even more to this
chapter and it's so short also the heck
because in the secret basement with the
dolls that sounds weird that we already
have seen before Robin who I'm happy to
see has not been captured by anyone yet
has a conversation with tetsu one of the
First characters we actually ever met in
wano well it turns out that uh this man
is actually kozuki Sukiyaki Oda father
who we all have thought to be dead for a
long long time this is such an
interesting reveal because it opens up
so many questions but since we barely
get any answers here I want to move on
for the moment and talk about Luton
Robin what the heck like how did you
know about pluton being in wano since
Alabaster and never thought about
mentioning it at least once not only
does this once again underline the fact
that Alabaster seems to have been allied
with the ancient Kingdom in some way or
form in this case specifically wano but
it also begs the important very
important question what is pluton really
is it a giant Battleship that is hidden
somewhere in wano or is it literally
momonosuke just how it was shirahoshi on
Fishman Islands I really do feel like I
have a hunch that we might be getting
some more lore on the ancient weapons in
the story quite soon with this reveal
but now let's move on to my personal and
I guess your personal highlight of the
entire chapter this right here who would
have thought that the cover of volume 25
would foreshadow the future four Empress
of the sea for the 25th anniversary of
One Piece like really Yoda Sensei just
how much did you actually plan the story
in advance is this an actual coincidence
I really can't tell anymore at this
point well buggy becoming an improve to
see buggy becoming an emperor of the sea
is just the biggest plot twist ever it
just throws up so many questions like
how did that happen is buggy actually
just lucky all through the way or is he
actually a secret Mastermind that has
been pretending all along was buggy the
pirate that Shanks was talking about to
the guru say to distract them from Luffy
I want to take my time and discuss this
in a whole video but for now if you
really want to understand how the world
government thinks and functions and how
the gorosei have ruled the world you
should really not miss out on this video
right here